what's going on guys this is rob and i
couldn't figure out what kind of video i
was going to make for today i thought
about doing a theory video but i was
like you know what let's have some fun
because you guys are digging the
editorial video that gordon made for
dragon ball super so i thought i'd talk
about dragon ball super too and here's
the thing man like let's let's talk
about gohan here for a second here's the
thing to understand ever since i was a
little kid gohan was my main man here's
the thing when i was a little kid i i
remember the first time i ever watched
dragon ball z it was in the middle of
the namek saga right because you guys
remember how it was back in the day on
toonami right they would do like the
whole series up into like up to like the
name saga then just like start over
again because they hadn't made any of
the new episodes yet for reasons that
i'm sure have been explained but i'm too
lazy to look up but i remember looking
at all those things right just watching
all that stuff
gohan was always my main guy right like
i remember the first episode that i ever
saw was the episode when they were on
namic when goku had first gotten there
and vegeta thought that goku was a super
saiyan then i was like okay this is kind
of cool then i watched the rest and then
they restarted it and i had to watch the
series all the way over again which was
still cool because i got to see all the
stuff that i missed out on before but
ever since gohan first went nuts on rat
right just like charged up and like
literally headbutted the hell out of
rider like dude he he headbutted radit
from hell like it was it was it was
amazing to see right and then you get to
like what is arguably the greatest
moment from gohan in the history of
dragon ball now there are some great
moments right when it came to gohan and
dragon ball z there's great moments when
he charged up and went crazy and like
attacked frieza wasn't powerful enough
to kill him but he turned some heads you
know what i mean frieza was just like
damn you know it was like wow like this
dude's pretty powerful like this kid
like it's ridiculous how op this kid is
i mean i remember like right like when
you were watching dragon ball z as a kid
you were always waiting for the moment
gohan got pissed off right now having
said that there's like the moment right
like the gohan moment which is when
gohan goes super saiyan 2. now here's
the thing i am well aware of the debate
that goes on out there in the the dragon
ball community where it's like the
japanese version and the history and the
significance and the meaning i don't
give a damn what matters to me when i'm
watching an episode of dragon ball is
does it get me hyped and i'm going to
tell you right now man that's probably
going to piss off a lot of people
don't care what got me hyped was the
english dub and i don't care what
anybody says man i don't care what
anybody says i mean i remember back in
the day right like when the internet was
relatively new and you managed to just
happen to find that treasure trove of
like clean japanese episodes with
subtitles you guys have been around the
block long enough you know what i'm
talking about right like you would just
come across that one website that had
all the files and they were in real
player back when real player was a
relevant thing that people had but it
was all the japanese episodes like every
episode of dragon ball z in japanese
with subtitles and it was clean it
looked good it wasn't like those crappy
ass grainy videos you know what i mean
where like they were recorded at like
30p right not even like 144 people just
like 30p where you can kind of make them
out sometimes occasionally you know and
then it's like all grainy and you can
barely make out make out the audio or
anything like that i mean like clean
episode right so you get that right like
it was cool seeing those things but the
english dub of gohan going super saiyan
2
let me tell you something like that dude
the music they play now there's only one
moment
in the history of dragon ball z that has
that same music that's more exciting
than the time when when gohan goes super
saiyan 2 and y'all know what i'm talking
about it's when vegeta does the final
flash on cell you guys remember that
scene you remember how op just how
ridiculously amazing that scene was when
vegeta's like charging up and he's like
stay right there and like they're
playing the music he's literally just
charging up this final flash and you're
like man what in the hell is vegeta
doing and he's just like charging up all
this energy right and like trunks is
like father you have to stop it you know
and vegeta is just like final flash it
like fires that [ __ ] off and the music
you get none of your choices
left it was the most hyped moment ever
in the history of dragon ball i don't
care what anybody says that [ __ ] had me
come out of my seat son but like here's
the thing anything right gohan goes
super saiyan 2. now i will say the
japanese version was cool it was not a
garbage version at all it was cool right
it was the the piece and like the bird
chirping and like it had some cool
moments whatever the english one that's
the one that i loved right that's the
one that i loved gohan goes super saiyan
2 dudes powered up all the hell right
you had to sell juniors you had like
goku and you had vegeta and all those
guys right this is back in the day when
everybody just hypothesized about power
levels you guys remember that no one
knows who the power levels are should
there be that one website who's just
like goku's power levels at 1 billion i
know that because how the hell are you
going to contradict me right it's just
whatever i want it to be right because
we don't know and so it was it was a
really really cool moment right really
really cool moment man like look like
when that happened in that moment when
gohan went super saiyan 2
son you knew she was about to pop off
because that was the general rule right
that's that's that's the dragon ball
rule right the gohan rule when she gets
quiet things pop off that's how it is
that's how you know it is with gohan
right like either that or he starts
crying like when he was a little kid he
started crying you were like man son
like do you want super saiyan 2 against
cell it was all like donkey kong san san
sun he was not prepared and it was the
it was the best thing right because he
absolutely just crushes this guy got a
little cocky right got a little cocky
but dude like like the the best dude
like the best moment the best moment in
the cell saga the best moment ever is
when like they're doing the kamehameha
attacks right so like you got you got
like super perfect cell who's firing it
off against gohan gohan's got one arm
right like literally he's on the ropes
his back's against the wall he's losing
you're like okay this is it it's game
over right like goku is it's a spear
form he's dead and gone so you're just
like okay how in the hell is he gonna
pull this off and vegeta out of nowhere
sun out of nowhere sun
fires off this last ditch final flash
takes takes up by surprise and goku's
like now's your chance and like gohan
just unleashes everything
overpowers this guy and disintegrates
cell and it was like man
man man let me tell you something
son let me tell you something it was one
of the best moments ever in the history
of dragon ball now let's get into the
whole reason why we're making this video
which honestly i had to talk about that
i had to talk about gohan super saiyan 2
greatest moment in the history of his
character we basically get like a we get
we get like a round two right like cell
max versus beast gohan not gonna lie
they should have come up with a better
name right like beast gohan it sounds
like an energy drink but they should
have come up with a better name than
that but it was still cool right like
gohan just becomes this ridiculously op
version of himself now the first
question i have to ask here and the
first question everybody has to ask here
is like how would super saiyan blue goku
stand up against like like beast gohan
right or even better than that right
goku using ultra plot armor right well
you guys call it ultra instinct but like
ultra plot armor come on man the guy can
just automatically block attacks right i
mean it's the most plot armor [ __ ] ever
right i know people are gonna be like
well he was prophesized okay cool so
they prophesized goku's plot armor they
told us it was gonna happen at like a
future point in time hey guys here is a
mode that goku can enter where he just
auto pilots everything right literally
at this point goku's fights are just
simulations in in like sports games
right you just sim the fight between
goku and whoever he's fighting right
it's the most plot armor [ __ ] ever
but like i firmly believe that would be
an amazing that'd be a fight for the
ages imagine like gohan like super
saiyan like like beast gohan with ultra
instinct right like ultra beast gohan
man like you can tell people just
salivating right they're already just
making up power scaling numbers right
it's just making up numbers off top of
their head right his power level is one
trillion because who gives a sh like
it's it's the coolest thing right but i
was excited to see it's the biggest
issue that i had in this fight between
beast gohan and and cell max is i wish
it had lasted longer i mean it was cool
that he fired off like the special beam
cannon of piccolo which is what it's
called here in the states it's cool like
it's got a name in in the japanese anime
which i can't pronounce but uh it's got
its own name it's cool that he used that
right and gordon made a really really
good point where he talked about how it
was gohan paying homage to his master
which is piccolo it's cool to see that
relationship's still very much intact
right then in a lot of ways because goku
was just a terrible father that piccolo
is more of a dad to gohan than like goku
is right yoku's like hey guys i'm gonna
bail on y'all for like 10 years why
because reasons peace and like that's
basically it but uh but nonetheless you
know it was cool to see gohan do that i
understand that time was limited given
everything that had happened in the
movie itself i wouldn't be surprised if
this is something that we're gonna see
in the show i don't know if it is i'm
sure the manga is far enough ahead to
where if it is going to be in the show
we will have already known about it so
i'm sure people already are aware if
it's going to be in the show or not i
would love to see this kind of
continuation right like sort of a a
beast gohan kind of following up and see
like a more complex and more
comprehensive fight i mean obviously
we're never going to get the kind of
nostalgia that we got in the fight
between super saiyan 2 gohan and cell
that's gone right as much as we would
love to see that that you know kind of
experience that again we won't we could
get close to it but there was nothing
like being a teenager and watching the
fight between gohan and cell and just
how it all unfolded and how it made us
feel because really the significance
behind that fight is the fact that it
had just been leading up to that point
for so many episodes ever since gohan
headbutted raditz and you knew there was
just this kind of hidden power that was
in this kid and it would just
occasionally manifest you didn't quite
know where it was going to lead i would
say that the super saiyan 2 gohan era is
actually more interesting than when you
got what is it the like mystic gohan is
what they call him ultimate gohan
depending on who you know on who you're
talking to different names for what's
effectively the same character i think
it was a little more interesting than
that i think was a little better than
that but you know i think that that kind
of nostalgia feeling's gone having said
that it was cool even if only for a few
minutes to kind of have a chance to
relive our childhood right to kind of go
back to when we were teenagers we were
sitting on the edge of our seats at
least at 5 30 pm eastern time for me
when i was watching dragon ball and and
just kind of reliving these moments
right this moment when gohan is fighting
cell the entirety of the earth's
survival rests on the shoulders of this
kid who's being reckless with the level
of power he has not concentrating the
same way goku had the way he was taught
by piccolo things like that just sort of
getting carried away with himself it was
great to be there and to experience that
moment i don't know if we're really
going to experience that per se if we
see this rolled over into the main
dragon ball super series but i would
like it having said that i love this
idea i love gohan like beast gohan i
love that gohan has this new level of
power i think this is kind of a
reflection of one of the issues that you
have with dragon ball which is just like
they've like i you know like when i look
at it it's just like i thought that like
gohan in like his ultimate form in in in
like the buu saga i thought that was
like all of gohan's potential unleash
and it's like well it was until it
wasn't until we changed it and then we
decided now this is this higher level of
power right so i think that's kind of
one of the issues you run into but the
reality is that when it comes to dragon
ball you just want to take that with a
grain of salt you're just kind of like
yeah i mean you know this was the most
powerful form this is as powerful as
goku's ever going to be until it becomes
more powerful you know like this is all
of gohan's potential energy until we
find out that he's actually got a little
more potential energy over there and now
it's unlocked and now he's beats gohan
because you know it's cool to see so
having said that i enjoyed the movie i
thought it was fun it was a blast and i
especially enjoyed the fight between
cell and gohan again i wish it had gone
on a little bit longer i wish there had
been a little more that happened there
but it was still cool to see how you
said that guys we're gonna bring this to
an end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later peace